[Applause]
healthcare workers trying to care for
coronavirus patients and carry out tests
from the city of Indore a chased and
attacked people who live here suspicious
if anyone who has contact with a corona
virus the area was barricaded to contain
to positive cases and keep 50 families
under isolation barricades were
vandalized in some offenders threw
stones apart from the assault police
will take notice of these two matters
police tried to convince people in the
neighborhood to allow health care
workers to do their job and the police
are target's too one officer was
critically injured when he was one of
several beaten and Muzaffarnagar in the
state of uttar pradesh after they tried
to stop people from gathering in
defiance of the lockdown attacks on
healthcare workers have been reported
elsewhere to a community health worker
in karnataka state says she and her
colleagues were attacked when they were
trying to spread awareness about
coronavirus and check if anyone had
symptoms they grabbed our phones we were
not allowed to call officials we have
been working for the past five years
we were never humiliated like this we
tried to explain to them that we are
here to help them and to gather
information about anyone who is
suffering
India's Health Ministry has condemned
the attacks if anyone has abused any
health care worker then it is a shameful
matter we request everyone not behave
this way again because we need the help
of our medical professionals as they're
leading this fight from the front we can
only get ahead with their support health
care workers aren't just fighting
coronavirus but also the stigma that
comes with it all of this you know
really horrible attacks on you know on
healthcare workers and doctors returning
from duties you know not allowing them
back into their housing complexes and in
fact in New Delhi the government has
decided to take all the doctors from one
government hospital and housed them in a
hotel so that they can be free of that
concern and can be taken care of
India's leading public hospital vote to
the government last week demanding
action against landlords who were
evicting doctors and nurses because of
fears that they might make others more
susceptible to the corona virus
various states have warned landlords of
legal action saying evicting health care
workers amounts to obstruct in public
servants India's Health Ministry
reminded everyone that these are the
same public servants who Indians came
out on their balconies and applauded
less than two weeks ago
Elizabeth puranam al-jazeera New Delhi